el congresista republicano George Santos
fue arrestado Y comparecerá ante el
tribunal Federal del distrito este de
Nueva York que este miércoles Santos se
enfrenta 13 cargos federales siete
cargos de fraude electrónico tres cargos
de lavado de dinero un cargo de robo de
fondos públicos y dos cargos por hacer
declaraciones falsas a la cámara de
representantes congresista congresistas
tanto demócratas como republicanos
llevan pidiendo la renuncia de Santos
desde que empezó el periodo legislativo
pero Kevin mccarthy presidente de la
cámara de representantes dice que
analizará los cargos antes de determinar
si cree que Santos Debería ser
destituido de su cargo
mccarthy agregó que como ha hecho en el
pasado hasta que no se pruebe culpable a
un congresista no le pedirá la renuncia
hay que mencionar que Santos podría
seguir siendo congresista a pesar de los
cargos en su contra ya que nada en los
requisitos de la constitución en Estados
Unidos prohíbe que las personas bajo
acusación o condena penal sirvan como
legisladores a excepción de que cometan
traición después de juramentar